you have to go to a dark place sometimes
to like get to that point
ooh
Lucy Hale opening up about her sobriety
Journey from my very first experience
drinking which was like age 14 up until
a year ago I have had a problem I've
never had a a period of my life where I
was a normal moderate Drinker it was
always let's go let's let's just I was
willing to just go to this crazy dark
place every time my brain doesn't
work the same way as someone who can
just have a glass of wine the actress
reveals on the Diary of a CEO podcast on
Thursday that she's battled alcoholism
most of her life it's just a topic that
might make people a little uncomfortable
I was like textbook binge Drinker like
blackout wouldn't remember what I did
what I said which is
scary in addition to suffering from an
eating disorder starting at age 13. it
was
all I thought about from the moment I
woke up until I went to bed at night how
much should I eat how much did I work
out I would step on a scale 30 times a
day I was eating so little that it was
shocking because I thought if I could
just be this number or this goal weight
then I'll be enough
she then details how her body image
became more difficult to manage when she
was cast in Pretty Little Liars at 20
years old I'm like okay well we gotta be
pretty we gotta be little
okay well we got this and It ultimately
it wasn't about wanting to be pretty or
little it was about this is scary my
life has completely
shifted overnight
millions of people are seeing my face
Instagram had just started you know it
was just sort of beginning my first post
ever on Instagram was me and of season
one of Pretty Little Liars
um and it was like my life was now under
a magnifying glass but Lucy doesn't
blame Hollywood for her struggles that
show changed my life grateful for it
grateful for all the all it brought to
me I get I now get to do all different
types of roles because of that show and
I'll never forget that you know I'll
always have gratitude for that she
celebrated her first year of sobriety in
January with a touching Valentine's Day
post on Instagram writing in the caption
bear with me this is an alternative
Valentine's Day post this is a post
about self-love and the greatest thing
I've ever done a January 2nd 2023 I
celebrated one year of sobriety you are
exactly where you need to be things
happen exactly how they're supposed to
and fans may see Lucy channeling that
energy into future projects the last
three uh projects that you were a part
of you also produced I'm curious is
directing something you're interested in
the future so I used to think no because
I
am a very like anxious person and it
felt like that's a big role to take on
you know the older I get I realize just
how creative I am and how many ideas I
have and that I think as I've reclaimed
my power is just taking my power back as
a woman or a human being I'm like no I
actually could do that
[Music]